what if a writer does not know if
they're a conceptual writer or an
intuitive writer yeah great question so
I can I can tell in 10 seconds but I've
been doing this a while so what I'll do
is well I can tell by reading it but
that's not going to be helpful to the
writer the writer can't necessarily read
it but here's what a writer can do so
I'll I'll ask a writer question so I can
tell from a writer and I haven't read
their writing so what I'll do is um now
they have to have written at least a
script so I'll say let's talk about the
last script
you uh why did you write it you know
what was your inspiration what was your
jumping off point what did you get
excited about I just listen and I can
tell in 10 seconds so if it's a
conceptual writer first of all they're
going to be answering from just their
voice it's going to be answering from
the more analytical intellectual part of
the brain that then you just can hear
that but also they're going to be
talking about uh they started with an
idea a concept o no one's done a
thriller where you know or this I
thought would be a really good comedy or
they'll talk about oh a twist ending
they had um or an opening story stuff or
they might be talking about world
conceptual writers love World building
so could be World building could be a
concept an idea part of a story a
beginning a twist ending a this a con
that's now when you when you talk to an
intuitive writer they're going to be
talking about it from a more emotionally
authentic vulnerable place and they're
almost always going to say well so
there's this character you know and it's
a character or or it's something
personal and they might be able to say
like I worked with a writer once and
she's like I just went through this
really painful divorce and uh I either
just cry myself to sleep every night and
drink or I could write about it okay so
that's an intuitive writer or sometimes
they don't even know they'll
say I don't know and they're almost
embarrassed but like I had to write this
I I just had to write this that's an
intuitive writer
so what is your inspiration what got you
excited another thing I'll ask is okay
so when you're working on this script
was there ever a point where you got in
a like it got tough like you got lost or
you you you didn't know what to do and
they're oh yeah yeah I go what did you
do and you know an intuitive writer they
they're going to find the solution in
the character and just what feels right
and the conceptual writer is like well I
thought you know for the someone who
reads it it' be good if this happens and
they're just coming at it from a
completely different
space not just to confuse this for a
moment I always get in my
workshops I get I'd say 90% of the
writers within a few weeks they know
they're conceptual or intuitive and
there's no gender to this I mean I have
equal amount of conceptual writers or
men and women same with intuitive but
there's always like one or two or three
writers who will say I'm so confused um
I really thought I was intuitive because
this but then I thought I was conceptual
when I do this sees I feel like I'm both
but I don't think I do either that great
exactly there's a small percentage of
writers I call them slidable so if you
think about like the um
conceptual and the intuitive and most
people obviously unless you've had like
brain damage you have access to both
parts and you use different parts you
know when you sleep you're using your
intuitive when you're solving math
you're doing the
ceptual um but most people will hang out
here as a writer or hang out here but
there's some small percent of writers
that just slide back and forth back and
forth so they're like oh yeah I thought
I was no I thought it was this and they
they're like kind of equally comfortable
they just slide back and forth but
they're not strong enough in either
space so they will just pick one space
stay there get really strong at it then
go over here and get really strong at
this if you are slidable
you should celebrate because that's the
hardest part so I'm I'm a DieHard
conceptual writer so when I was doing
this training it was so hard to turn off
the conceptual brain it was so hard to
go over here and when I was over here at
some point I'd have a conceptual thought
or conceptual concern I just goop and I
would just stay here um I had to learn
how to slide back and forth effortlessly
that's the hardest thing for me to teach
someone and some people naturally do it
I don't know why but they do so
it's possible someone listening to this
they answer the questions that I asked
and they're like I kind of think I'm
both that is possible but you might need
to get stronger at one or both
sides